si on parle beaucoup des commerçants qui
ne peuvent plus travailler en raison du
confinement une autre colère monte en ce
moment celle des lycéens qui se sentent
en danger dans plusieurs établissements
de france des manifestations plus ou
moins pacifistes se sont déroulées pour
bloquer l'accès aux établissements dans
le but de contester le manque
d'application des protocoles sanitaires
dans les lycées pour de nombreux élèves
cette injonction à se rendre en cours
est une mise en danger de la part du
gouvernement tant que tout n'est pas
fait pour assurer leur protection une
grève qui s'est déroulé sur tout le
territoire comme devant le lycée colbert
ce matin à paris
à 14 heures rue du bac une manifestation
était prévue à quelques pas du ministère
de l'éducation nationale
alors comprenez vous la colère des
lycéens mathieu élève de terminale es
présent aux événements de ce matin va
tout nous raconter
merci monsieur battre avec nous merci à
vous merci beaucoup 18 ans mathieu est
ce que vous connaissez les jeunes vous
êtes en terminale pas vraiment puisque
moi 18 ans j'étais en quatrième et en
co2 vous étiez à colbert le lycée où il
ya eu le plus de tensions aujourd'hui un
lycéen qui s'est fait
un petit peu bousculé par un policier
même fortement à un simple il aux
urgences maintenant ah oui qu'est ce qui
a eu un côté n'ont pas concrètement il
ya une charge de policiers à 16h45
nous on était là on avait manifesté on
est totalement pacifique et il ya des
policiers qui sont venus qui nous ont
chargés qui nous vient hanter cette ce
lycéen là il à l'arcade péter maintenant
il aux urgences moi j'ai peur pour lui
en fait là aujourd'hui bas et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est incroyable c'est
d'affrontements entre forces de l'ordre
et lycéens qu'elles sont vous voulez pas
plus de 20 élèves par classe est ce que
vous sentez en danger au lycée
aujourd'hui
évidemment qu'on sent en danger au lycée
aujourd'hui simple on arrive devant le
lycée
le protocole sanitaire pour l'instant il
n'est pas appliqué dans tous les lycées
on est nombreux devant les grilles on
est nombreux dans les couloirs on est
nombreux dans les cantines pour
l'instant il n'y a pas un endroit où on
sent en sécurité au lycée aujourd'hui
nous on a peur quand on va au lycée
moi j'ai une amie elle me dit sa mère
elle est malade elle a peur de rentrer
chez elle le soir parce que si elle lui
donne de grands navires us à mr
potentiellement on peut mourir c'est
ultra inquiétant la situation
aujourd'hui dans les lycées alors et
jean michel maire vous n'êtes pas
d'accord vous avec j'aimerais bien
croire mathieu surtout sur la
manifestation
je ne veux pas défendre les crs
absolument mais j'ai eu les crs chargé
les manifestants pacifistes en rouge à
sequins et chaque fournée de côté sa
balance des trucs très bon bah si sympa
qu il était advenu ont fait pas que j'ai
c'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt à la
peinture d'accuser les crs de violence
assure n'attendre c'est pas dans ça
s'est passé on a que ça pour ça que je
dis j'aimerais la batave la question va
parler c'est bon ça quand la question
est donc et pour les lycéens
les lycéens craignent pas plus loin même
mois que les autres qui vont travailler
ils vont qui vont faire leurs courses si
on est obligé de faire les courses et
que c'est important
beaucoup plus de monde et lycées que
dans les commandes à la maison mais
trouver tout le monde connaissait pas
dire qu'ils sont le maire est exposé un
barnum et c'est alors il faut pas faire
grève c'est manon il ya les vioques
qu'ils sont énervés la wii moi je trouve
honnêtement que faire une greffe j'en ai
vu plein qui avait le masque là donc il
n'était absolument pas protégé donc
pardon mais au nom d'une sur une
nécessité de protection allait se [ __ ]
dans un endroit où il n'y a pas de
possibilité de protection je ne trouve
pas que ce soit très intelligent
actuellement c'est la presse j'ai quand
même l'impression que ça fait longtemps
que vous n'avez pas été
parce que oui ça je vous comprends
cent deux roues c'est vraiment des
souvenirs lointains parce que quand vous
êtes dans les couloirs quand vous allez
à la cantine quand vous faites la queue
pour aller au sahel et bien sûr c'est
bondé
oui vous êtes colère la personne tout le
monde se poussent même jégou mais
comment comment tu peux comparer ça avec
le fait qu'ils manient face au devoir
bien sûr ils sont obligés de manifester
parce que là on leur nom leur ont leur
ils vont pas où ils vont pas au lycée et
à ce moment là ça va être de leur faute
de ne pas aller s'inscrire
donc comme ils doivent aller s'inscrire
c'est apparemment ils demandent que les
choses soient adaptés il y avait des
groupes des groupes b à l'époque est bon
on fait des coupes mathieu et thomas tu
vous dites que vous n'avez pas envie
d'avoir des morts sur la conscience
exactement nous là on a peur s'ils ont
interpellé coronavirus nous contaminer
nos frères et soeurs de contaminer nos
parents si potentiellement peuvent être
vulnérables et ça ça pèse sur les
épaules des lycées alors si c'est le
travail ou la réponse du gouvernement
il trouve déplacé et un des sons que
vous vous réunissiez en ce moment a dit
la réponse du gouvernement ils vont
trouver que c'était déplacé indécent
jean michel maire vous êtes d'accord
laissez-le pas répondre entièrement
d'accord c'est vrai que les pays où nous
irons on prend des risques aussi tous
les jours voilà on peut se faire
contaminer aussi par deux chants etc
dans les transports au travail n'importe
au maxi exactement gilles évidemment les
piges intéressant aussi
et je suis bien placé pour dire ça va
leur plaire que dès qu'on peut un peu
[ __ ] le bordel sortiront m
j'étais du bon sens c'est tout moi j'ai
la rage est connue 1068 mon tir donnons
lui connu mais jen 168 ce v6 avait 68
ans avait d'autres raisons de manifester
mais qu'elle s'appelle ça pète
et moi je comprends la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui pas que j'étais j'ai eu
cet âge mais j'ai fait les mêmes choses
mais c'était à l'époque il y avait les
garde-mobiles chapeau des pénétrations
jamais personne n'a voulu le dire mais
il ya eu des morts à 68
mais ça tout le monde a fermé sa gueule
et moi je comprends la jeunesse en tout
cas ça nous fait plaisir de recevoir
beauxis relais on dit parfois que les
jeunes ne respectent pas les mesures
sanitaires là ils sont exemplaires
ils veulent être divisée il faut qu'on
les aide on a sacrifié les universités
maintenance et les lycées c'est pas
possible
faut réquisitionner des gymnases faut
diviser déclassant de l'embauché des
gens on peut pas laisser comme ça nos
jeunes être contaminés et contaminer les
aînés ils sont exemplaires et demande de
l'aide il faut les aider et l'on s'en
occupe
ils sont en train de faire tout à la
main d'enfant du 6 mai 20011
olaizola vraiment il en pré retraite les
jeunes manifestent contre les autres
jeunes qui font des fêtes ou surtout
battre serait pas de mathieu laissé
répondre mathieu la voir non mais
également nous on nous fait peser tout
le poids de cette crise sur les ai pas
bien sûr si généralement qui est
responsable de ça c'est le gouvernement
qui n'a pas prévu la rentrée scolaire
nous on n'a jamais demandé 35 ou 40 pas
le cas vous faites des faits se soient
révélées par jacques de tous voilà
excusez moi jean michel brun des jeunes
ou pareil comme un dieu couvre déjà
résolue contre l'absence de mesures il
ne manifeste pas pour ne pas aller en
cours au contraire ils veulent y aller
ils veulent pas faire la fête
il ya des contradictions dans le
gouvernement on leur dit bah oui bah
aéré vous pouvez passer des fenêtres
anti justement des périodes la cantine
comment vous faites il ya ya ya ya lieu
impossible d avoir les masques monjack
masque voilà je suis alors dit mathieu
vous êtes inquiet bah oui évidemment
qu'on est inquiet j'aimerais vous pas
aller passer le bac cette année vous
êtes inquiet pour le bac pour le niveau
pour savoir si vous allez y arriver ou
parme inquiet parce que si jamais les
lycées fermés on va devoir se retrouver
tout seul chez nous parfois sans nos
professeurs sont nos amis pour réviser
le baccalauréat
ça va être super dur va y avoir une
masse des chèques énorme nous on a peur
de décrocher déjà l'année dernière on a
su bien confinement pendant plusieurs
mois on était cinq professeurs c'était
super dur et là ça va peut-être être
rebelote nous c'est pas possible en fait
cette situation là jean michel vous
nommant parce que toute manifestation
6700 politique et contre le gouvernement
et contre le gouvernement etc
c'est pas contre l'as cucq à la crise
sanitaire la crise sanitaire on la subit
tous ont manifestement dans la rue nous
parce que nous aussi on prend le métro
il ya de belles choses que ça on n'est
pas que des pancartes dans la rue voilà
ça c'est dit les jeunes se rebellent
très bien mais j'ai été jeune aussi j'ai
aussi manifester mais faut pas non plus
faire mais je voulais vous répondront à
leurs paroles c'est bien plus grave qu
est ce que tu es monsieur tout le monde
évidemment comme une fête qu'on leur
gouvernement c'est bien jean michel
blanckaert ya pas prévu c'est trop alors
voilà on est de lier nos jours
évidemment qu'on manifeste contre le
gouvernement
pauli gouvernement qui sait pas nous
protéger les derniers six mois j'étais
d'année syndicales mais goody tu fais de
la politique quand tu finis syndicale
mais bien sûr qu'elle gérait côté le
gouvernement pour les hommes a stationné
salaires ou les conditions de travail
par rapport des lois qui nous mènera ce
qui me qui vont contre mes intérêts je
fais une grève politique dans technique
il sauf que quand il faut pas se réunira
plus de 6 soit là ou pas de
manifestation c'est nicolas pernikoff
c'est ce qu'on appelle c'est ce qu'ils
disent est une injonction paradoxale
c'est à dire que d'un côté on essaie de
les lire et l'école pressé de sauver
l'école en envoyant les élèves à l'école
par bon c'est pas le cas non plus en
toutes les écoles de france et cayenne
injonction paradoxale quand même des
mesures sanitaires
non mais il ya des mesures sanitaires
qui ont été prises quand même dans 80%
des écoles
donc là à ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement les 10 à 15 % 86
patients non mais c'est pas attendez
c'est pas le cas partout en majorité ce
n'est pas le cas en france
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est le
bordel à après effectivement un moment
donné il faut bien se faire entendre
bah oui où ils veulent aller à l'école
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quand même que
l'année dernière énormément de
décrochage scolaire moi j'ai moins fils
qui est en première aujourd'hui qui a
commencé à faire des collages et qui
passent le bac en fin d'année c'est
ingérable de faire l'école à domicile à
sinjar à sérieusement tu avais serait
mathieu est ce que vous avez vraiment un
message à faire passer ce soir au
gouvernement et à tous les gens qui sont
comme jean michel maire qui disent que
c'est déplacé ce que vous faites
actuellement est comme moi mais vous
savez ce que déplacer aujourd'hui c'est
d'envoyer des élèves à 35 ou 40 par
classe sans avoir peur qu'on attrape le
coronavirus nous nous a envoyés au lycée
alors que c'était dangereux
on nous a mis en danger c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un nouveau protocole sanitaire
publié jeudi dernier parce que le
protocole sanitaire qui avait été publié
à la rentrée ils nous mettaient en
danger
c'est un scandale d'état en fait on a
été mis en danger par le gouvernement
c'est pour ça qu'on veut des mesures du
gouvernement
concrètement là on nous a mis en danger
on est on est énervé quoi on ne jamais
en danger on a mis toute la société en
danger aussi parce que ça se mobilisent
c'est pas que pour nos droits c'est
aussi parce que nous on a peur ensuite
de rentrer chez nous de voir nos parents
de voir nos frères et soeurs de
décontaminer nous on est vraiment énervé
contre ce gouvernement qui a mis toute
notre famille en danger
voilà alors qu'est ce que vous répondez
ça
il avait le moral ça c'est pas une
injonction paradoxale fin j'aurais pas
je pense que ça a été une politique ça
n'a plus rien de salutaire effectivement
je suis désolé il est il est honnête
mature et pour jean-michel souvent
répondu je réponds je peux comprendre
ses interrogations et ses craintes
sauf qu'il faut reconnaître aussi que
c'est un mouvement qui est
ultra-minoritaire la cérémonie comme un
lycéen la plume la grande majorité des
lycéens ne pense pas ça voilà on donne
la parole ce qu'il casse et qu'ils
manifestent dans la rue
90% des messins ont été en classe
voilà c'est ce que je dis voilà